[Musica]
ma voi ricordate la prima volta che il
computer è entrato a casa vostra a casa
mia è entrato negli anni 80 sotto forma
di tastiera che si attaccava al
televisore era l'aquarius il cugino
sfortunato del como dr
non avevamo le cassettine di memoria e
quindi bisognava scrivere dei lunghi
codici comprensibili per vedere qualcosa
sullo schermo la leggenda narra di mio
papà che stete sveglio una notte per
programmare un caleidoscopio era molto
orgoglioso e felice che mio fratello non
sapevamo cosa farci con un caleidoscopio
quindi non eravamo particolarmente
colpiti la verità è che il computer vero
e proprio entro qualche anno più tardi
elusa 9 farci di tutto si installano i
videogiochi
c'era un enciclopedia virtuale con cui
potevamo fare di tutto potevamo
addirittura andare su internet a un
certo punto un paio d'ore al mese per i
nostri genitori non c'erano particolari
limiti su quello che potevamo fare con
il computer
la verità è che erano molto più
preoccupati della televisione si parlava
della teledipendenza quanto tempo si
passava davanti alla televisione
addirittura negli anni ottanta
all'inizio erano arrivati cartoni
animati giapponesi è un sacco di
famiglie erano preoccupate per questa
forma di intrattenimento così nuova
all'epoca una delle poche voci fuori dal
coro
fu quella di gianni rodari che scrisse
un articolo proprio in difesa di ufo
robot in quell'articolo gianni rodari
iscrive diceva parecchie cose
interessanti la prima è che lui diceva
che a casa sua non c'era la televisione
è a casa dei suoi genitori non c'erano
nemmeno gli albi illustrati e questo mi
ha fatto pensare al fatto che ogni
generazione di adulti si confronta con
delle tecnologie che non gli
appartengono e deve in qualche modo a
imparare come gestirle come utilizzarle
anche con i bambini e rodari dice che
dovremmo imparare a chiedere ai bambini
perché gli piace così tanto quella
tecnologia ascoltando le loro risposte
con sincera curiosità senza pensare di
sapere già qual è la risposta giusta
come facciamo noi adulti di solito el
altra cosa importante che riceve rodari
è che quello che ci dovrebbe interessare
in che modo ai bambini vedono queste
immagini e se ne appropriano le fanno
diventare loro le usano per alimentare
la loro fantasia per trasformarle in
qualcos'altro
nonostante l'articolo di rodari si sente
spesso anche oggi parlare di quanto
tempo passiamo davanti al computer
cosa ci faranno i bambini tutto questo
tempo davanti al computer ed
effettivamente siamo abituati a vedere
il computer e la televisione come
qualcosa di molto simile
hanno entrambi uno schermo funzionano
con l'elettricità
sono invenzioni recenti però se ci
pensate con la televisione non possiamo
connetterci con altre persone
non possiamo usare la televisione per
costruire dei programmi per creare delle
cose io penso che dovremmo cambiare
prospettiva e iniziare a vedere il
computer meno come una televisione è più
come un pennello una matita qualcosa che
possiamo tirare fuori e usare per creare
per esprimerci un po di anni fa ho
scoperto un posto pieno di persone che
vedevano il computer proprio come un
pennello erano i coder dojo di cover
dote sono dei club gratuiti gestiti da
volontari in tutto il mondo dove i
bambini imparano a programmare ci arriva
accompagnati dai genitori con il proprio
computer si porta una merenda che si
condivide con gli altri e si passa
insieme del tempo scoprendo in che modo
si possono fare delle cose con il
computer
usiamo tantissimo una piattaforma che si
chiama scratch è una piattaforma
gratuita che permette di costruire dei
veri e propri programmi è un linguaggio
di programmazione ma non solo permette
anche di condividere le proprie
creazioni online vedere quello che hanno
fatto gli altri commentarlo studiarlo e
utilizzarlo per creare qualcos'altro
la prima volta che sono andato un
covered oger a bologna nel 2013 e
all'inizio come al solito si danno delle
regole perché è la prima volta che viene
una regola è che gli adulti non possano
toccare il mouse e la tastiera l'altra
regola è che si può copiare potete
alzarvi i bambini andare a vedere cosa
stanno facendo gli altri e infine se
vedete qualcosa che vi piace qualcosa
che vi incuriosisce potete esplorarla i
computer non esplode potete
tranquillamente non ascoltare quello che
sta dicendo l'insegnante e curiosare il
programma di fronte a me c'erano vari
bambini tra cui edoardo un bambino di
sei anni e mezzo non sapeva proprio
leggere benissimo e anche usare il mouse
e la tastiera
tant'è che ogni volta che doveva
cliccare qualcosa in alto si sbracciava
sul tavolo con il mouse si distraeva
facilmente perché trovava un sacco di
cose che gli interessavano in quel
programma e quindi chiedeva aiuto agli
altri o andava semplicemente a curiosare
che cosa avevano fatto quindi alla fine
dell'incontro mentre quasi tutti avevano
fatto un programma animato dove si
vedevano delle cose che succedevano
sullo schermo e aveva scoperto che c'era
un punto del programma in cui si poteva
disegnare e va dedicato un sacco di
tempo a costruire questo robot che
incombeva su una città e sparava fulmini
e saette che mi chiedevo ma è andata
bene cosa ha imparato e la risposta
hp sentendo l'orgoglio con cui lui
raccontava i suoi genitori che quella
cosa l'aveva fatta con le sue mani e la
curiosità e la passione di tornare a
casa e scoprire come animarla come fare
delle altre cose che aveva fatto più
fatica quel giorno ero stato io perché
non potevo aiutare edoardo prendendo il
mouse e facendo le cose al posto suo non
potevo dire agli altri di stare in
silenzio o dire a lui di fare quello che
stava dicendo l'insegnante quel giorno
ho dovuto cambiare il modo in cui
immaginavo di insegnare a usare il
computer ai bambini e ho capito che la
cosa più importante è creare le
condizioni attorno ai bambini perché
loro si sentono liberi e abbiano il
coraggio di esplorare liberamente e di
costruire con le loro mani
per questo motivo la cosa più importante
era dare ai bambini dei progetti
concreti da costruire qualcosa che
potessero smontare che potessero capire
come era stato fatto che potessero
mostrare agli altri che potessero
studiare e ricostruire condividendola
con gli altri un'altra cosa molto
importante è che i bambini avevano tempo
e spazio per seguire le loro passioni e
i loro interessi
edoardo prima di voler animare su
personaggi a fare magari una storia un
videogioco ha voluto disegnarlo con le
sue mani e inoltre in questo ambiente
c'erano altri bambini con cui non si
condivide semplicemente l'anno di
nascita come a scuola ma con cui si
potevano condividere interessi e
passioni con cui si poteva imparare e
costruire assieme e infine in questi
ambienti
c'è un clima giocoso che non vuol dire
che si gioca e basta ma se invece
pensate quando vi impegnate a fare
qualcosa che vi appassiona vi divertite
navi costa che fatica ma soprattutto in
un ambiente giocoso quando state
giocando avete uno strano coraggio non
vi sentite aggiudicati se provate a fare
qualcosa vi sentite liberi di provare a
esplorare
di buttarvi fare qualcosa che ancora non
conoscete negli anni ho portato ho
provato a portare questo tipo di
esperienza in tanti contesti diversi
a scuola o nei centri estivi utilizzando
qualsiasi tipo di tecnologia che mi
permettesse insieme al computer di
creare e di lasciare i bambini liberi di
esprimersi quindi c'erano robot ma anche
leggo cartone colla computer qualsiasi
cosa permettesse bambini di sentirsi dei
creatori e inoltre altre volte mi sono
trovato a raccontare agli adulti e
genitori che cosa facevamo e mi veniva
fatto la domanda ma quindi che cosa si
impara quando impariamo a programmare in
un ambiente dove il computer viene visto
come un pennello
impariamo di certo un sacco di
importanti concetti legati alla
matematica l'informatica a come creare
dei programmi le variabili i dati ma non
è solo questo impariamo anche a prendere
un problema complesso e tradurla in
qualcosa di semplice che un computer in
grado di far di eseguire impariamo a
usare una soluzione in contesti diversi
a prendere un problema e spezzettarlo e
analizzarlo e provare la nostra
soluzione più e più volte sbagliando e
capendo che l'errore è qualcosa di
importante se vogliamo imparare nuove
cose in questi ambienti
impariamo a condividere le nostre idee
ea usare le idee degli altri per creare
qualcosa di nuovo in questi ambienti
ci divertiamo a esplorare e soprattutto
in questo tipo di ambiente i bambini
possono cambiare prospettiva su come
si vedono e su come possono esprimersi
per entrare in contatto col mondo e
conoscere il mondo quando impariamo a
programmare in un ambiente dove il
computer e un pennello non stiamo
diventando degli sviluppatori perché
vogliamo fare gli sviluppatori da grande
mio figlio a 4 anni e mezzo non sa
scrivere e non sa ancora leggere
io non vedo l'ora che lui impari a
scrivere ea leggere ma non perché voglio
che diventi uno scrittore di romanzi o
un abile oratore perché non vedo l'ora
che lui possa imparare da solo perché
non vedo l'ora che lui possa leggere dei
libri e scoprire nuove cose scrivere le
sue idee raccontarle agli altri quando
impariamo a programmare in un ambiente
dove il computer è visto come un
pennello possiamo imparare tantissime
altre cose non è facile cambiare
prospettiva su come immaginiamo il
computer e l'insegnamento e
l'apprendimento però rodari ci ha dato
sicuramente una buona idea
dovremmo imparare a fare delle domande
con curiosità sincera e ascoltare le
risposte dei bambini e poi l'altra cosa
importante è che non vi sto dicendo di
imparare a programmare stanno svegli la
notte come aveva fatto mio papà per
costruire un caleidoscopio che alla fine
non ha mai programmato nella sua vita ma
vi chiedo qual è il vostro caleidoscopio
quali sono le passioni che vi tengono
svegli
qual è l'ultima cosa che avete imparato
perché se farete da esempio e creerete
un clima aperto l'apprendimento
all'esplorazione in casa permetterete ai
bambini di utilizzare il computer in
maniera creativa e quello che gli
resterà in testa non saranno tanto i
pixel colorati sullo schermo si
ricorderanno che eravate curiosi della
passione che vi animava e che non vi
siete mai arrese
[Applauso]
[Musica]